[Musique]
on l'appelle le crime du 21e siècle
le marché du faux la contrefaçon qui se
moque de toutes les frontières y compris
des nôtres tant que ça si métaux
produits de luxe personne est en danger
mais lorsque des produits visant à
assurer notre sécurité sont contrefaits
c'est une toute autre histoire
on est en milieu hospitalier s'est trop
préoccupé entre nouvelle enquête sur une
forme de contrefaçon méconnu qui a
touché le coeur de nos hôpitaux
[Musique]
juste avant l'aube dans les entrailles
d'un hôpital de la ville de québec
les visiteurs inhabituels à la recherche
de pièces contrefaites
je ne voudrais pas qu'un être cher soit
brancher un appareil qui pourrait
flancher à cause d'un disjoncteur après
que faire comprendre et faire des
contrefaçons 2d disjoncteur censée
protéger les circuits électriques mais
potentiellement dangereux sont au coeur
de cette opération restée longtemps
secrète
[Musique]
début décembre la police de toronto
réussit une importante saisie de faux
vêtements et accessoires de luxe pour la
plupart une forme de contrefaçon bien
connu mais dans le lot des produits plus
sophistiqués
il fait valoir
so personne est à l'abri
plus aucun secteur n'est épargné par la
contrefaçon la ligue que c'est l'avocat
canadien le plus actif dans la lutte à
la contrefaçon
il mobilise policiers douaniers et
entreprises contre cette industrie
souterraine évaluer des milliards de
dollars l'industrie de la contrefaçon
augmentent plus rapidement que les
ressources pour la combattre dentifrice
contenant du glycol a été retiré du
marché canadien dans les derniers mois
car la contrefaçon touche désormais des
produits dangereux pour la santé et la
sécurité
tous
comme ces lampes animé pour enfants qui
prennent feu je pense que le
gouvernement devrait faire un peu plus
attention la sécurité du monde de
courses qui vont du sublime sur les
marchés et tout récemment ses milliers
de fer plat à charny près de québec
la partie qu'on met dans la prise de
courant est mal fait et à l'intérieur
les spécialistes nous disent que le
filage n'est vraiment pas conforme
c est tout le monde aujourd'hui veulent
en avoir pour son argent dans tous les
domaines mais viser seulement le plus
bas prix c'est une invitation à la
contrefaçon des notations focale fallait
la majorité de ses produits vient d'asie
mais ce qu'on a découvert
accidentellement au sous-sol de
l'hôpital de l'enfant jésus en 2002
illustre un autre type de contrefaçon
celle médine canada une découverte qui a
fait frémir toute l'industrie électrique
canadienne
nous avons découvert un disjoncteur à
l'étiquette contrefaites et il a fallu
des mois pour le retirer parce que cela
exigeait de fermer cette unité au
complet on parle ici d'un disjoncteur de
type industriel qui peut valoir de 500 à
quelques milliers de dollars en cas de
surchauffe
il protège les circuits électriques
celui découvert à l'enfant jésus avait
été altéré
l'enquète a déterminé que le mécanisme
intérieur avait été trafiqué qu'il ne se
serait pas déclenché au bon moment le
disjoncteur peut rester ainsi les années
au moment où on en a besoin
il ne fonctionne pas et on se retrouve
avec une catastrophe sur les bras
le cas de l'enfant jésus fait craindre
le pire
le risque d' incendies pousse le
fabricant quand le gamin a porté plainte
à la grc
c'est le début d'une longue enquête à
laquelle la régie du bâtiment va
collaborer étroitement que je voulais
mettre en relief c'est la complexité
qui est la nôtre en ce qui a trait à la
détection d'un j'entends contrefaits on
a collé que le panneau et de couverts de
pièces métalliques et que même le joker
latina toute la façade du panneau nous
et camoufler la régie entreprend
discrètement l'inspection d'autres
hôpitaux
on a visité quarantaine d'hôpitaux dans
la région de marjah est peut-être une
trentaine dans la région de québec ou
même moment deux incidents surviennent
dans des hôpitaux ne panne de courant a
plongé dans le noir de pavillons de
l'hôpital royal victoria de montréal la
nuit dernière et pendant 80 minutes les
locaux de l'urgence et des soins
intensifs ont été privés d'électricité
les infirmières ont dû assurer la survie
d'un
et a maintenu en vie grâce à un
respirateur artificiel c'est un
disjoncteur qui est en cause
etait-il contrefaits l'établissement
refuse de répondre à cette question
malgré nos demandes répétées mais
l'incident démontre à quel point la
femme d'un seul disjoncteur peut avoir
des conséquences dramatiques de quand
même beaucoup de filage en cause dans ce
fameux panneau électrique ou l' incendie
a pris a pris naissance hier soir un
mois plus tard un début d'incendié à
l'hôpital maisonneuve rosemont force le
transfert d'un patient en pleine
chirurgie c'est encore un disjoncteur
dans un panneau électrique qui est en
cause le panneau en question ont été
récupérés pour faire des expertises
revient dans l' expertise nous a permis
de déterminer s'il s'agissait de joker
contre fait non il était tellement
détériorée le dip anouk on n'a pas pu
avoir le coeur net les disjoncteurs
industriels sont vendus habituellement
par des distributeurs autorisés mais il
ya aussi un marché parallèle celui de
l'usagé il y a huit ans le fabricant
cauteleux à main intente une poursuite
en cour fédérale contre un vendeur
d'usagé après l'avoir surpris à vendre
des produits contrefaits
à l'époque la grc refusent d'enquêter à
gabès pourrissent de gratte les
policiers sont les premiers à le
reconnaître
lorsqu'un fabricant porte plainte pour
contrefaçon
souvent ils ne peuvent pas y donner
suite faute de ressources des just dance
le fabricant reproche à distribuer tech
de ville saint-laurent de changer des
pièces à l'intérieur de certains
disjoncteur usagers ce n'est pas encore
interdit à l'époque mais ça reste une
pratique problématique
j'ouvre le chantage en place deux
composantes et instituts et ça peut
porter à conséquence parce que ces gens
alors les mots n'ont pas nécessairement
expertise se sont plaints des jax
entreprises distribuent t qui reconnaît
toutefois avoir fabriqué et coller de
faux étiquette la cour le condamne à
vingt trois mille dollars d'amence
[Musique]
l'année suivante en 2000 y est tout
indique que d'autres contrefacteurs sont
à l'oeuvre et que leurs produits ont
atteint les hôpitaux
[Musique]
oh
tout laisse penser c'est un inspecteur
qui est venu nous voir be kind 10 km et
de gendarmes policiers l'hôpital la cité
de la santé à laval vient de réaliser
des travaux de rénovation
lorsque la grc identifie cinq
disjoncteur contrefaits dont un qui est
liée aux débordements de l'urgence
magnétique et sur les aliments tels
débordements
est ce que dans vos devis il était
spécifié que c'est joker de dette est
neuf ouais c'est clairement indiqué dans
nos 18 mai
il était tellement bien reconditionnés
qu'on pouvait pas même si on avait les
deux pièces sont à côté de l'autre ça
prend vraiment un expert pour venir à
bout de déterminer que
lice il avait été brisée qui habite au
war 3 autres hôpitaux de la région
montréalaise sont victimes
un disjoncteur est repérée à l'hôpital
pierre boucher à longueuil on en trouve
quatre ans autres au pavillon saint luc
du chum plus encore trois à l'hôpital du
sacré coeur
[Musique]
et lanka est révèle que plusieurs
marques sont touchés
[Musique]
le marché des disjoncteur usagers est
tout à fait légal ils s'approvisionnent
dans les chantiers de démolition comme
celui de l'usiné gm de boisbriand où on
en a récupéré des milliers mais d'autres
sources sont plus douteuses ils
proviennent souvent de son de sinistrés
au cours de l' enquête on a découvert
que des disjoncteurs venaient des états
unis et que certains étaient endommagés
par l'eau les contrefacteurs les polices
est collé de fausses étiquettes
canadiennes et les remettait sur le
marché la contrefaçon n'a pas touché que
les hôpitaux avec des teneurs de
construction des carottes des pièces
contrefaites construction de raphaël
picard vient de doubler la superficie de
son supermarché à saint-amable en
montérégie
lorsqu'il reçoit la visite d'un
inspecteur de la régie du bâtiment des
gens d'âge on avait de tous les niveaux
la partir de 20 ans était défectueux qui
étaient contrefaits
ces pièces là il y en a qui veulent
jusque qui dépassait 3500 $ c'est qu'au
total en aviez pour plusieurs dizaines
entre 35 et 40 dollars de johnson qui
était contrefait
vous avez là janka qui est à l'origine
de notre intervention c'est carrément le
fabricant qui est informé par un
dissipateur autorisé qu'un entrepreneur
en électricité s'était procuré des
panneaux est dictée avec un nombre très
limité de gionta cei a mis la puce à
l'oreille à dire quelque chose qui
cloche
les vingt-deux disjoncteur contrefaits
protège des circuits qui soutiennent des
centaines de milliers de dollars
d'équipements dont dépend dans leur tour
des milliers de denrées périssables pour
la voie des causes 1,5 g à cause d'un
joggeur non viables dans des risques
pour la sécurité et des risques de
pertes financières extrêmes exactement
monsieur picard exige de l'entrepreneur
qu'il remplace les pièces contrefaites
mais ces problèmes ne font que commencer
[Musique]
nous sommes dans un des laboratoires de
l'association canadienne de
normalisation
on reste ici des produits pour s'assurer
de leur conformité aux normes un produit
électrique qui ne détient pas le sceau
du csa ne devraient pas être vendus au
canada mais ce souhait maintenant copié
par des faussaires les contrefacteurs
s'attarde à l'aspect extérieur du
produit pour qu'ils paraissent
authentiques et notre marque est un gage
de qualité
on a trouvé deux fous logo du csa sur
les disjoncteur contrefaits saisis par
la grc
on recherche le goût du csa comme une
signe de qualité
mais même ce n'est plus garanti plus
rien est à l'épreuve des faussaires mais
la présence du sceau du csa assure que
nous veillons sur la situation que le
fabricant y veillent aussi
[Musique]
le fabricant cote le rameur dont la
plainte est à l'origine de l'enquêté
policière a préféré ne pas nous accorder
d'entrevue c'est finalement au compte
gouttes que la régie du bâtiment nous a
révélé l'ampleur de la situation et
retiré combien on à le faire le tri au
total une soixantaine de disjoncteur
contrefaits ont été identifiés à
l'hôpital de rimouski à beauceville à
québec un à l'hôpital jeffery l2 à
l'hôpital laval
l'hôpital saint sacrement en posséder
six l'hôtel dieu de québec
4 mais c'est l'hôpital saint françois
d'assise à québec qui a été le plus
sévèrement touché
il nous a ouvert ses portes cet impôt
est évident de savoir faire
mais bon pendant toute une surprise pour
vous dans d'apprendre ça effectivement
pis c'est sûr que si je peux faire
l'analogie c'est toujours la même
manière si quelqu'un pour la
connaissance qu'il ya des faux billets
qu'ils sont en circulation peut se faire
rattraper ici on a saisi pas moins de
this disjoncteur sait jusqu'où asie est
longue et l'eau il était vraiment
flagrant l'heure parce que j'en avais
pas aucun coin quand on voit ce qui
arrive alors que ç'avait été j'avais
était démangé lui j'avais trois juges
face à un des plus problématiques qu'on
ne lui l'eau les disjoncteurs ont été
installés lors de différents projets de
rénovation le plus vieux en 1989 le
disjoncteur que vous aviez densifier
protéger quel circuit en 1989 le premier
dossier touche un secteur en néonatalité
comme l'année aux nappes c'est une place
pour le poker et de rien il rien et
qu'ils veulent c'est ce que c'était jean
charles devait bien fonctionné selon les
autorités aucun accident imputable à un
disjoncteur contrefaits n'a été rapporté
mais le danger n'en est pas moins réelle
de ces disjoncteur peuvent exploser et
la force de l'explosion peut entraîner
des blessures parfois mortelles en plus
de causer d'importants dégâts matériels
et même un incendie schneider electric
est un autre grand fabricant mondial
ces marques square 10 et fédérales
pioneer ont été contrefaites et saisi
dans les hôpitaux
je suis sûr qu'il ya eu des accidents
mais souvent l'équipement était trop
lourdement endommagé ces images montrent
la force générée par l'explosion d'un
disjoncteur contrefaits comme ceux
saisis dans les hôpitaux
en allant somme est jusqu'à tout
récemment on ne cherchait pas de
disjoncteur contrefaits parce qu on en
ignorait l'existence
plusieurs électriciens et vendeurs
d'usagé à qui nous avons parlé reproche
aux fabricants d'exagérer les dangers de
la contrefaçon pour protéger leur marché
c'est sûr qu'on veut la santé de notre
entreprise mais nous avons une
obligation morale d'assurer la sécurité
de ceux qui utilisent nos produits
henri buisson et ses inspecteurs
parcours maintenant le québec pour
informer les entrepreneurs ou ici des
ingénieurs des changements récents au
code de construction ce qui nous importe
c'est de sensibiliser
d'une part les inspirateurs ceux qui
oeuvrent sur le terrain
le code interdit désormais la remise à
neuf des dix chanteurs ce boîtier mouly
conséquence directe du problème
découvert dans les hôpitaux nous avons
emmené avec nous un chanteur sous bois
timoulay la régie espère mettre un terme
aux problèmes qu'elle considère très
sérieux des disjoncteurs contrefaits
savage auteur de cette nature ça
n'arrive pas dans ce qu'on appelle
communément un baggies - cycle le
fabricant d'origine
il va se faire un devoir de livrer dans
une belle boîte cartonnée avec toute son
éducation
il est fier de son produit
dans son supermarché raphaël picard a
demandé à l'électricien de remplacer les
22 du chanteur contrefaits découvert
dans l'agrandissement de son commerce
lorsqu'il a ouvert savoir gérer mcclean
route janka était dans des agendas
s'abriter dans des sacs ziploc enfin g10
étrange écologique vous vous utilisez -
carton vous utiliser des sacs
réutilisables pour vos produits
mais je trouvais ça un peu spécial
d'avoir des gens dans des sacs surtout
au fait que j'avais corriger les
situations vécues vérifier l'exactitude
des travaux et qu'est-ce que vous avez
découvert que les nouveaux deux auteurs
étaient aussi contents fait et je
retombais la case zéro tout était à
refaire
nous avons joint cet électricien qui
pratique toujours
il affirme n'avoir été qu'une victime
lui aussi dans cette affaire dans le cas
des hôpitaux les disjoncteur douteux ont
presque tous été installés lors de
travaux de rénovation commencés gionta
était entré justement avait atteint 9 la
structure électriques des hôpitaux
c'était souvent par l'entremise de sous
traitants donc en électricité
ce sont les contracteurs qui offre la
plus basse soumission qui obtiennent ces
contrats et la tentation est forte
d'acheter des pièces à rabais chez des
distributeurs non autorisées c'est de
savoir si c'est une p l agent a eu sa
place au lieu de 1500 ambiance
le symbole
sont-ce pas d'histoire il ya peut-être
des gens qui sont moins vertueux que
d'autres petits prennent des moyens
illégaux ils rentrent un prix plus beau
pays pour avoir la même marge de profit
prendre des moyens légaux
ça doit se voir un peu dans tous les
milieux notre enquête nous a permis
d'identifier plus d'une vingtaine
d'entrepreneurs électricien qui ont
installé des disjoncteurs contrefaits la
corporation des maîtres électriciens du
québec confirme qu'aucun n'a fait
l'objet de mesures disciplinaires ou
alex ans
cela n'a pas de sens tous ceux qui sont
impliqués dans la chaîne de distribution
de produits contrefaits devrait avoir
des comptes à rendre et on doit chercher
à déterminer s'ils ont agi en
connaissance de cause donne mais rien
est un ancien électricien devenus
ingénieurs présents à la rencontre
d'information de la régie du bâtiment et
gabon il raconte sa mésaventure avec un
disjoncteur neufs achetés pour un grand
magasin du centre-ville
vous avez acheté un disjoncteur 9 que
vous avez payer le plein prix de plein
prix viennent environ 1400 pièce qui il
avait l'air de quoi dans son emballage
29-19 poli le bate like it épaules ils
souhaitent en place le ribault en avant
une bonne qu'en définitive 9
et puis la boîte et neuf accords deux
mois plus tard ça le chauffe et l'a
finalement j'ai appris je rende service
de cap diamant pour faire une inspection
complète pour voir si nous pouvons voir
quelque chose a dit tabriquet est pas
bon site une remake de rigueur qui lui
fait retrouver seul avec le fabricant
ils ont changé tout l'anneau à huy
non seulement le disjoncteur neuf
étaient contrefaits
il provenait d'un distributeur autorisé
[Musique]
cela signifie que les produits
contrefaits ont même et filtrer la
chaîne de distribution les jt
[Musique]
nos hôpitaux ont été fouillés pour
trouver des disjoncteurs contrefaits
nous avons nous les moyens respecter
tous les lieux publics susceptibles d'en
avoir et si nos hôpitaux n'était que la
pointe 10 berne
[Musique]
la piste des disjoncteur contrefaits
même bien au delà des hôpitaux
c'est un trafic qui s'est étendue sur
plusieurs années vous en avez trouvé
dans des hôpitaux
est-ce que vous en est-ce que vous avez
exploré la possibilité qu'il y en ait
dans des écoles par exemple dans
d'autres bâtiments publics qui seraient
préoccupants ont n'avons pas effect
actuellement les effectifs qui nous
permettrait de mettre en place des
opérations de grande envergure pour
contrer le phénomène web regorge double
nous avons demandé l'aide d'un
électricien pour inspecter quelques
endroits publics pour ne pas nuire à ses
clients nous allons taire son identité
et les vues visiter les édifices se
compte par niveau que veulent les
excuses dans l'équipe au sein desquels
on peut trouver ce genre d'équipement là
tout autant il n'est pas facile même
pour quelqu'un d'expérience de démêler
le vrai du faux
on dirait que c'était gratter
regardez tout le temps on dirait
vraiment que c'est et graphique comme si
ça avait été ouvert ce disjoncteur
suspects se trouvent dans un aréna notre
électricien reprend la route pour
poursuivre son enquête
celle de la grc elle s'est terminée en
2005 avec une perquisition dans un
commerce de ville lasalle
metropolit a électrique est accusé de
contrefaçon est condamnée à soixante dix
mille dollars d'amande au moment même où
ce effectué la perquisition
fx de ladite entreprise il y avait une
entreprise de la bosse je me souviens
bien qui venait de confirmer ou
distributeurs de montréal à l'effet
qu'il y avait trouvé telle cruauté
donc on peut présumer que c'est
jean-louis fonctionnement dans une
certaine mesure en réseau l'entreprise
jm pomerleau à saint martin de beauce
fait aussi l'objet d'une perquisition et
pierre coupables à son tour la compagnie
est condamné à près de quarante mille
dollars band
une troisième perquisition dans le
bas-saint-laurent révèle des milliers de
vieux disjoncteur entreposés dans une
grange non chauffé mais personne ne sera
inculpé il y en avait d'autres
nous avons dit à la grc en avoir
identifié une dizaine au québec mais
cela dépasse les frontières du québec il
y en en ontario en alberta en
colombie-britannique
ce problème existe à l'échelle
canadienne stopper l'activité des
contrefacteurs s'avère difficile au
canada on doit faire la preuve que les
contrefacteurs agissent en connaissance
de cause
malheureusement les procureurs de la
couronne hésitent à porter les
accusations
notre système ne considère pas toujours
la fraude comme un crime grave dure aux
états unis la contrefaçon est un crime
punissable par l'emprisonnement et par
des amendes qui peuvent atteindre des
millions de dollars nouvel arrêt de
notre électricien au premier coup d'oeil
l'équipement a l'air neuf mais un examen
plus minutieux soul et des doutes
l'aspect général de chacun des briques
un bon s'apercevait que étape autour de
mes couleurs
le plastique des puits avec du plastique
blanc gens ont faim
cet endroit à vocation culturelle a été
rénové en 2003 selon nos informations
les devis prévoyait du matériel neuf
alors que les disjoncteur sont
clairement identifiées comme étant
remanufacturées
de sept jours nous avons soumis les
étiquettes à l'analyse d'un expert
au moins trois d'entre elles sont
contrefaites y compris le sou du csa
[Musique]
j'étais déjà commencé il ya une semaine
j'entends lui il y avait vraiment une
surchauffe a été vraiment très très
chaud c'est un moment là j'avais pris
leur barrage puis à 60 ans est en
réalité du routeur était capable
normalement supporter ça reste un grand
pas si on se fie à l'étiquette suez
détient les ij enquêteurs devront être
analysés en laboratoire pour déterminer
s'ils sont dangereux ils proviennent
d'un autre commerce qui n'a pas été
accusé
nous les avons découverts dans le centre
du québec
une région qu'on croyait à ce jour
épargné par le problème on ne retrouve
pas ce genre de dispositif de protection
dans l'existence donc vous avez pas que
tout le monde panique
bien que la situation soit très
préoccupant pour la rencontre ce n'est
pas ce que nous avons inclus
lors de notre rencontre avec le
fabricant chemin de la compagnie est
aussi préoccupé par la contrefaçon des
dix chanteurs de petit format en
amérique du nord s'est vendu dans des
petites boîtes comme celle ci ce sont
des petits disjoncteur les genres qui
peut se retrouver dans votre maison
cheney a deux a repéré aux états unis
depuis deux ans sept cent mille de ces
petits disjoncteur résidentiel
contrefaits en chine ces images ont été
tournées lors d'une perquisition par les
autorités chinoises certains peuvent
exploser
lorsqu'ils sont soumis à des tests
cheney 2 vient de découvrir que quelques
milliers de ces petits disjoncteur
contrefaits ont déjà fait leur entrée au
québec
si on considère qu'une maison compte
entre 10 et 15 disjoncteur cela
représente entre 200 et 250 résidences
qui serait actuellement protégés au
complet par de faux disjoncteur
des choses pour l'instant c'est le
premier cas que nous détectons mais ce
n'est certainement pas le seul
c'est dans la région de montréal je
crois que oui la piste des disjoncteur
révèle le peu de moyens dont on dispose
pour faire face à la contrefaçon
qu'elles soient d'ici ou d'ailleurs le
problème ne fait que commencer
pendant sur saône même pas l'ampleur
sous-estimé le phénomène amène un
sentiment de sécurité qui pourrait bien
s'avérer faut lui aussi qu'